it is hard out here for a pimp now that
might seem like an unusual choice for an
Academy Award nominated song but Chris
also forgot Chitty Chitty Bang Bang and
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
so tonight one of these nominees joins
the roll call of Best Original Song from
crash in the deep music by Kathleen bird
York and Michael Becker there by
Kathleen bird York from Hustle & Flow is
hard out here for a pimp music and lyric
by Jordan Houston
Cedric Coleman and Paul Beauregard
from Transamerica travelers groom music
and lyric by Dolly Parton's and the
Oscar goes to is hard
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Jordan Huston
Cedric Coleman and Paul Paul regard
Oh
hey we want to take keep drawing our
choreographer yes now help me out a
whole song in Regan's Lisa L is our
mom's our whole family thank you Jesus
isolate no here's we get us a chance
that caddy me without no camera you know
saying guilt cakes everybody I love you
hell I got plenty town LaVon no no veils
now on thank everybody has done a honor
yeah
once again our families little Christian
rose up going down say oh by George
cooling my favorite man show when I
first met
haha
you know what I think it just got a
little easier out here for a pimp
I think it did now I'm worried now I'm
worried now I know that three 6 mafia is
going to get into it we itzhak perlman
x' posse I know it and then they have
only one way to solve it
dreidel off alright how come they're the
most excited people here tonight why is
that thrill rule that's how you accept
an Oscar